it isn't for the British government or
any other government to tell the Israeli
government how they should respond to
the massacre of their civilians but I do
think it's important to just bear in
mind that we can in countries like
Britain or should keep our own house in
order I see no reason why Britain should
have for so many years been a retirement
home for members of the Revolutionary
Islamic government in tan one of whom as
I wrote about in the magazine recently
lives in Harrow I see no reason why
hamas's backers should live in the UK
and I don't see any reason why their
supporters should live in the UK after
Jews have been massacred for being Jews
by Hamas in this Isis likee fashion
treat the the people who support that as
we would the supporters of Isis and if
you can't remove their citizenship and
expel them from the UK at least
prosecute them and imprison them under
the 2006 terrorism act for the
glorification of Terror